dans nouvelle star mais à quelle place a
terminé à belle beille ah ben oui vacher
compris la question à la cabane à quelle
place dans nouvelle star
bahman toile ffs non non moi je dis rien
n'ont qu'à bien fini troisième à dix
huit ans il avait barré la dignité at il
indiqué je prends le 3 il y avait trois
ne prend le trou et pas tout à fait une
carrière exceptionnelle alors que le
gagnant de cette saison c'était steve
estatof et impudeur ouais mais si on l'a
aussi débloquer des trucs un album qui
était sympa bien toi c'est vous qui
présentait à l'époque sur ces lacombe et
a dit tout à l'heure que c'était jimmy
fallon vous allez encore une série la
nuit dans la love qu'est-ce qu'il en
existait pas de chimie fine à leur
époque là ouais mais lui non plus merci
regardez on à ta première apparition
télé les images de son audition a été si
on les a rien au bout et ça voulait dire
on est heureux la bohème
la bohème nous ne mangions ou un jour
sur deux merci en fait il faut
feuilleter le jury on les a reconnus et
pourquoi pas il faut les flouté qu'ils
sont en droit de se régler les questions
de droit voilà je pense que c'était le
meilleur jury aussi
ouais c'est vrai nom alors à mettre
justement vous avez fait vous vous
arrêtez vos excuses avec nikos vous avez
fait nouvelle star benjamin castaldi
j'ai un coup de fil équipe comme
animateur benjamin castaldi nikos un os
est passé sait déjà c'est pas la même
époque donc je pense que c'est pas la
même manière de faire est d'animer je
vous trouve exceptionnel désormais pour
moi quelqu'un qui donne beaucoup
d'énergie pour avoir fait les émissions
avec lui il met à l'aise il est très
professionnel je pense que c'est un mec
génial si on choisira main je choisirais
pas de manière plus que fait nico ce
dont ils sont plus d y joue plus dans la
même cour ils font que fut la même chose
je veux dire c'est pas comme s'ils
étaient en vie que je travaille plus à
ça que tu travailles plus été plus
animateur de de télé crochet sur autre
chose à la télé crochet convoi plus
qu'on peut plus vous comparez mai mais
moi j'étais adoré à mon époque je
trouvais que c'était un animateur
bienveillant et j'ai aimé savoir que tu
étais là avant et à la fin de mes
chansons à l'époque tricherie et m
pokora d'ailleurs où sont une bonne
ambiance entre vous très bonne ambiance
au sur 0 risque était contente de le
refaire je suis très contente
alors là ça va être cool enregistrés
alors ça y est vous les faits ouais donc
ses kilos jury à la soprano voiture et a
menacé j'aurais pas d'animal patrick
fiori vous êtes 4 maintenant dans le
jury c'est comme chez les grands et non
sincèrement c'est vrai mais tellement
c'était ma première mais j'étais comme
une folle de le faire ou pas bah c'est
pas ça c'est que légalement ils font
quoi si tu dit j'aimerais chanter comme
vous ils ont ils seront ils sont
exceptionnels mais vraiment c'est
j'espère que les gens vont avoir l
ressentir c'est un niveau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous l'avez rencontré comment pains sur
scène vraiment direct vous avez répété
avant avec lui donc c'est impressionnant
déjà coton répétait-il et on ne peut pas
imaginer comme ça parce qu'il est
tellement c'est un monstre sacré donc là
on a l'impression qu'il va être comme ça
aussi
enfin en dehors de la scène il est d'une
humilité
là je parle au présent arrivé parce
qu'il était d'une grande humilité
vraiment et on s'est fait vraiment de
l'avoir d'avoir partagé ces moments avec
lui je pense que c'est une énorme chance
pour dans la carrière d'un danseur
devons mettre à l'aise et ça va ce qu'on
doit avoir une avant une appréhension
quand même hein c'est vrai que une
profondeur dans le regard dans l'est il
dit peu de mots mais les mots sont
justes c'est honnête honnête on oublie
pas c'est un vrai rocker
[Applaudissements]